and now the eastern conference finals
how good
was 20-year-old tyler hero in game four
the miami rookie had scored 45 points in
109 minutes off the miami bench in the
first three games
then went off in game four 37 points and
35 minutes including
17 in the fourth as miami put boston
in a 3-1 hole but he was just one of
four guys with at least 20 for the heat
bam adebayo went for 20 and 12 rebounds
and sat down with our rebecca harlow
so ma'am heading into the next game we
could obviously
see that you were in some pain how are
you feeling today
i'm good i'm straight uh a little shaken
up but
i'm good now so no worries about
getting back on the floor no no i'll be
playing your room protection
and then the way that you're able to
pull tys away from the basket on the
other end of the floor has made a big
difference in this series
take me inside your mindset your role
your job
in terms of making the winning plays
people said a lot
i'm the heart and soul of this team so
you know when you have that type of
responsibility you got to back that up
and
throughout these playoffs i was backing
it up and i got to continue to do that
six different players on this team
averaging in double figures
how much joy does it give you to see
another guy
step up on any given night like what we
saw from tyler hero in game four
it just shows how versatile our team is
and
you never know who's gonna have the
night that's that's what i like about
the team
it's unexpected and the beautiful thing
about it is
we're not afraid to keep free feeding
the hot hand
we don't care because at the end of the
day we want to win
we don't care who gets the glory man at
the end of the day we all got one goal
that's that's the championship close-out
games are always the hardest
what do you expect in game five
you don't know what to expect because
you know that backs against the wall so
you don't know what to expect but for us
we just need to go out there
you know take one possession at a time
make sure we get shots on goal
and and just keep playing the defense
and i feel like we
we have another level to get to to where
we can play
48 minutes of miami basketball
thanks rebecca and our friends at espn
have that game at 8 30 tomorrow night if
bam doesn't know really what to expect
out of game five what do you expect
well i expect boston to to come out and
play excellent basketball but also
expect the heat to come out and play
basketball the key is not to play cool
the key is not to say we have we have
one game to make the final
the kids to focus do what you've been
doing make sure you continue to play
together make sure you continue to play
hard
make sure you continue to play
consistent and listen i want to give
props to
dragic you know his you know name is not
mentioned a lot he's older but
i think he should get the same respect
as cp3 been getting
older guy putting up numbers doing a lot
for his team and again
the recipe for them the last couple
games you can get four guys and 20
points
you can win and one of those guys with
37 like
tyler hero had like tyler hero had
what are you looking at shaq like that
for because he's averaging the same
points cp3
first of all that's just an insult to
cp3 i'm not going to let you get away
with that oh it's not listen drawdrick
is having
he's had a good postman chris paul
career
i said it i'm validated okay i can say
yeah listen
it's better to be quiet and be thought
of food and speaking to move all doubt
oh look out okay maybe come across there
put that plexiglass on your ass
but i'm validating more validation
listen listen yeah
about that project is a nice player
don't compare him to cp3 that's not fair
i didn't say compare him to three cp3 if
you listen if you shut that what did you
say
i said he should get the same respect
what what i didn't compare him to cb3
what does that mean then it means you
respect cp3 for certain things you
should give him a certain respect that's
what i respect but i
don't don't compare them to the stop by
comparing them i do i don't compare you
to agreement
russell hey you know what i'm the shack
or wilt cp three
team sitting around somewhere brad dart
why are they talking about me all of a
sudden
all guys are rings thank you i said brad
dardy yeah
tyler hero 37. he could go
i mean i mean he played extremely well
you know he's a versatile artist gilmore
he's a virtual young player columbus
chucky brown came into
larry he came into the league as a
three-point shooter he's sure
but his ability to have get handled a
basketball
is what's allowing him to be you know
special in this playoff
uh series uh consistency can you come
back and do it because
they're gonna now now you're really on
the scouting report
you know it's kind of like when you
first go around that first time in the
nba
and you know you start killing in your
first rookie season in the second
but right after all-star break the
double teams start coming quicker
they're coming quicker tyler so be ready
tomorrow
they're rotating faster or not rotating
off you i would love to see what he does
but that was a heck of a performance
because his versatility handling the
basketball
getting into the lane and not standing
like and
and i brought that up i think with um
cp3 not standing on the three-point line
when jimmy butler or bam has the ball he
cuts to the rim
making other things happen and
defensively has been great you know he's
you know we you wouldn't think that uh
that would be a strong shoot for a guy
who's known as a shooter but his defense
has been just as impressive well and you
to me
they got to be careful because if you
cheat off him you go about duncan
robertson and jay crowder
those two guys they get going as a rep
this to me is a perfect example
of a like it takes more than talent to
win basketball games
because the celtics that's why we don't
play games on paper
that mime he team is very well coached
they are tough mentally they don't make
mistakes
you got to give coach poe a lot of
credit you know they have done turned
doctrine robertson into a terrific
player
i've always liked jay crowder and let me
tell you something you know we had cal
on the other night
bam adebayo is terrific
and they got the leader and jimmy butler
shaq's guy dragic has been fantastic
but man hard three like who he's been
cp3 like
i just stopped him glad yes well played
jet well played
but if you just play hard and smart man
keep it up
go a long way not just be people again 8
30 tomorrow night on
espn more
on inside the nba in just a minute
anthony avec keep your dad alive